a few days ago my boyfriend and I were
heading out of the house and we were
waiting for the elevator when this
happened we are getting off the elevator
you are getting on but we are getting
off first
now at that moment what I really wanted
to say to him was what the fuck but that
would be rude right so instead I said
what the fuck what the fuck what oh that
was just weird that was just fucking
weird and don't get me wrong I think
that we should treat each other with
respect and compassion and understanding
until they give us a reason not to I'm
being an asshole
but I'm doing it with a smile which
makes it okay no no it does not but
don't just call other people out on
their bullshit I mean sometimes you have
to call bullshit on yourself we can't
eat all this ice cream bullshit and I do
can eat the entire carton we don't use
the prop gun like way too much what no I
don't yes you do I do and you have too
many cats get out I feel like we've all
kind of gotten used to communicating
through implication rather than directly
stating things we'll drop hints and
we're gonna you can all it brings her to
five now how cool cat Wow instead of
saying what we really want I want a baby
I'm just kidding but seriously put a
ring on it in all honesty I don't regret
calling that shit out my only regret is
that I wasn't Whittier in the moment but
we are getting off first yes your
majesty
a path has been cleared for thee hurry
my love make way for our king see you
next Monday stay awesome Gotham